trong thông viên ông đúng anh tròng ngày 1 bởi thành tạng khăn định sẽ gặp tổng nha
bài mẹ putin mà không đặt ra yêu cầu ông putin phải gặp tổng thông của quay nha
vô lúc đi mẹ dễ lệ sĩ trước.
ông thăm cho biết, của các thực định là nhà ngăn chẳng trên chẳng và ông sẽ làm mọi điều để có thể đã được điều đó.
Tế bụng này chẳng vô của thông tin trước đó từ một số mỗi tin nhà chẳng, cho rằng của các dơ lấy đạong nha
và của quay nha là điều kiện tiên quyết cho hội gị thật định miếng ngà.
Về phía nha, ông putin trước đó để xuất tổ chức của gặp bếng tròng tại các tự vương của rộn thông nhất
nhưng cho rằng chưa đến thời điểm để gặp ông sẽ làm sĩ.
Kính à và Mỹ điều sáng nhận kế vạc tổ chức hội nghiệp thông định vào tổng tối
nhưng chưa công bố cuộc thệ thời gian hai là địa điểm.
Đúng không thấy này, diễn ra sau chuyện thăm Việt, quay nguồn đặc phái viên Mỹ istif with coch trước đó chỉ một ai.
Tự khi nhập trước hội thăm một tổng thông thông nghĩ liên tục thuốc đầy đàn phản nhằm chấm rất sổn tổng quay nha
và gần đây đã là thẳng trọt cũng đàn thật đám để mắt sửa vá chất nhận thảo thật nước bánh.
Nếu không sẽ đường mắt thêm các biển phát triệu phát.
Về phía u cuối nha, tổng thống vô lâu đi miệ gi lần khi nhận mạnh, cho ông phải thăm giá trên trình hoặc bình,
giọc cuối nha là một phần không thể phát dời của AU.